it's the day of the cooking competition
with mukbang and my Thai television
debut the macdanne crew are setting up
in a district called bang low on the
outskirts of Bangkok a week ago I could
only cook a pad thai today I'm putting
my neck on the line and taken on
Thailand's top chef
I've been told to show up on set at 10
a.m. on the dot hello how are you good
to see hi I'm Gordon Pyke so where is he
that late of the day what does he like
when he arrives on set first was a
person he has a coal town
he didn't find his own place to sit
pretty yeah make up well as TV show it's
Palin TV show we always do make that
once Oh bless look I love mom and who
are the judges
one is mcdhh Aang's father Luke Dan's he
is quite famous he's like a Thailand
Michelin Guide McCain's father yes it's
a famous food critic yeah
I don't I know the corners nervous no
one likes competition damn it I'm gonna
I'm gonna really enjoy doing this
because he's so cocky and I'm really
cocky too it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be really really fun
come on mukbang Wow
[Music]
mcdhh and I have agreed to cook three
dishes each as soup a stir-fry and a
curry
they'll be blind tasted lucky for me but
Dan's dad will be joined in the judging
by two other top food critics he's here
he's arrived and knowing him he's
probably a makeup or something I don't
have to win I know I already work one
I'm not trained as a Thai chef but what
I've learned the last week has been
phenomenal great insight and nothing
really posh which is nice but the real
scary thing for me today is that it's
not just about cooking up against the
mukbang trying to entertain those food
critics the whole of Thailand's watching
[Music]
Hey look who's here how are you what
occur nice to see you too yeah we're all
thinking what an amazing week
and this team of chefs say all these
shifts on the side those are my tears my
staff let me say look at you I have five
of them so you wanted to start right
away
well yes okay okay are you ready
okay pissing my pants sell every sitcom
me cat pee said male hey man come on
millennion get over chef Gordon Ramsay
so what do you say so what do you cups
oh good
we're going to cook three dishes yes I'm
on my Jack Jones as well I got nobody
all ready to go yes okay right a good
luck by the way excuse me
so I can just say for me because I'm
feeling a little bit homesick Ready
Steady Cook when you're ready yeah just
for you are you ready yes
Ready Steady Cook excellent
I'm starting with my version of gang
hung lay the northern pork curry
first up the paste so garlic salt
chilies with lemongrass in there is your
paste made of course in Thailand all
that spend all that time doing it and it
has to come out looking like this I know
I don't taste it for the heat
see you next week see you next week Bam
Bam Bam
I'm fining off the paste just like the
sausage Queen Missy the rod showed me
then the pork goes in which I've dusted
with cinnamon for an extra layer of
spice then I'm adding fish sauce for
saltiness cane sugar for sweetness and
some dark soy for color
you just stick your fingers in my dish
would you like me to mess up your face
you know you're sweating like crazy
can you swim no give it'll be down there
auntie my [ __ ] walk again yeah mcdhh
and army of assistants have done so much
prep he's racing ahead with his pork and
green banana curry I know maybe in the
center of Thailand I hadn't got hoping
he'll win in but hey Braveheart
if I'm gonna go down I'm gonna go down
in style brave words when you look at
what I'm up against unbelievable so I
don't do it a thing I just cook while my
Co is cooking I really need to bang bang
the spices for my southern style soup
Tom DeLay like a really nice fragrant
hot sour soup but taken from the
southern style with lots of fish squid
shrimp oysters as well which is nice
going back to the dive just as I start
to get excited about my prospects
there's a hitch with my hung Laker II
just caught at the bottom so it just
tastes a little bit burnt
damn damn damn damn damn [ __ ]
but it's too late to do anything when
tangs father another two judges are here
my father is probably the most famous
man about food in Thailand sir
he knows you so you are somebody even in
Thailand
the clock's ticking down the judges are
waiting mcdhh and all done I've left my
chicken stir-fry
to the last minute I'm finishing it off
with a fried quail's egg are you ready
yes all right our dishes are going to
the judge's table they won't know whose
is who but they'll decide if I've done
enough to win them over and beat my dang
I'm not sure if I want to know what
they're saying about my food never never
ever grace the table food critic always
come back to bite you on the ass finally
the results delivered course-by-course
don't long nap knee Cup and judges
verdict ooh so mukbang baby hurry
Borden's stir fry no favorite as at all
my new kite Ana Thailand has been the
final stop on my Southeast Asian Odyssey
I'm thrilled it's ended on a high
Yamini end result was was good as please
I beat him on one dish this has been a
big eye-opener loved every minute of it
I've had the adventure of a lifetime
[Music]